Good day, everyone, and happy New Year.
I'm Jack Van Horn from the University of Southern
California.
And I'd
like to welcome you to the next webinar on
big data to knowledge, guide to the fundamentals
of data science.
We're absolutely delighted to have Dr. Ian
Foster from the University of Chicago and
Argonne National
Laboratories here to discuss why the cloud
matters for data science.
Dr. Foster is a well-regarded computer
scientist based at the University of Chicago,
where he is a professor of computer science.
And he's also the Director of Data Science
in the data science and learning division
and distinguished fellow at
Argonne National Laboratory.
He received his bachelor's degree from the
University of Canterbury in New
Zealand, and his PhD from Imperial College
in London, England-- both for computer science.
And is well known
for his work on the developments of grid computing,
of the Globus network, of how to move data
around efficiently
on the internet.
And his work involves developing tools and
techniques which allow people to use high
performance computing technologies to do quantitative
things new and easily.
We really like to welcome Dr. Foster, and
I'd like to welcome you to the audience to
text in and submit your
questions via the little questions submission
system here.
And I will work to gather those up and ask
them on your
behalf of Dr. Foster towards the end of the
hour.
Without further ado though, I'd like to turn
the webinar over to Dr.
Foster to tell us why the clock matters for
data science.
Ian, the stage is yours.
Thank you, Jack.
Good morning.
Good afternoon for those on the East Coast.
Thanks for joining.
So what I want
to do today is talk to you about cloud and
hopefully tell you a few things that you don't
know about it and give you
an idea of why it is important.
I think a very fundamentally transformative
technology that we should all be deeply
familiar with.
And in some cases, working how to apply it
in our science.
So my first slide here quotes a few interesting
assertions by the Gartner Group about cloud
computing.
This is
from a fairly recent report of theirs.
And it has some interesting observations.
The first bullet there asserts that
many large enterprises will be moving to largely
cloud only strategies for new IT.
In other words, they'll be
deploying new data systems, computing systems,
and so forth not in-house, but on resources
provided by
companies like Amazon or Google or Microsoft.
Increasingly, those applications are going
to be mission-critical.
That they're going to be getting more tech
specific, moving towards using a container
rather than virtual machines to host things
and well say a little bit about
that later.
That they'll increasingly be using AI technologies
and learning and data science technologies
that will
increasingly be cloud hosted.
And starting to use a technology called cloud-native
serverless computing which I'll say a bit
more about as well
because I think it's significant when we think
about how we might create data science applications
that we intend
to scale to large numbers of users.
So let's sort of-- just by way of background--
now, let's move on and spend a
bit of time talking about what cloud computing
is and how one might be able to use it.
So first of all, perhaps though, I'll just
spend a minute saying, well, why is it that
cloud computing is able to do all
these wonderful things?
Why is it that people, at least in enterprises,
are looking so seriously at running large
and
complex applications on cloud computing.
Well, first of all, it's due to the economies
of scale that are inherent in
the extremely large deployments that are operated
by a cloud provider.
So this is a Google machine room I think near
Chicago.
But there are many of these warehouse scale
computing
systems being operated by a growing number
of companies.
And well, it's sort of a fascinating picture.
You can
see the enormous sizes that they are able
to operate and, therefore, that translates
into certainly issues of
scalability-- economies of scale in terms
of operations, also reliability.
And obviously perhaps, also has implications
for things like security.
You've got very dedicated professional staff
operating and ensuring the security of the
sort of systems.
So, arguably, cloud computing systems are
more
secure than whatever might be operated by
your home institution.
When people use the word cloud, I'll just
mention briefly, to refer to a variety of
different technologies.
You'll hear
people talking about private clouds or academic,
or community clouds.
These tend to be clusters operated inside
a machine room in an institution running certain
software that will allow access to certain
storage models and
computing models.
But mostly I'm going to be talking today about
public cloud, which is the sorts of systems
that I just showed you a
picture of.
And I think that's an important distinction.
Public cloud tends to have a far richer set
of services.
And it's
those services that I think are really part
of what makes cloud computing exciting.
So let's listen a minute now talking about
what the cloud is.
So, in my view, you can think of cloud computing
as
providing three different sets of capabilities
to users.
As One that probably many of us are familiar
with is you can
think of the cloud as a virtual computer.
It's something that lets you run a virtual
machine, will store a file-- run
many virtual machine, store many files.
Just the things you do on your own on your
workstation or institutional computer, but
doing it in the machine room
like the one that I just showed you.
And of course that has certain benefits.
We can, for example, deploy a virtual
machine and run an application that perhaps
requires more resources than we have available
locally.
Perhaps that uses a specialized hardware device
like a graphical processing unit, GPU, that
we don't have
available locally.
But it's really not fundamentally different
from what we do in our ordinary, everyday
computing.
The second model of cloud computing is as
what you might call a lab assistant.
It's a set of software services that does
things that we could do ourselves locally
but is perhaps or more efficient to
do remotely.
We all make use of the sort of software as
a service side of cloud computing everyday
if we use
Google Docs or Google mail or some travel
planning service and so on and so forth.
And there are a growing
number also of more scientific software as
a service offerings available.
We'll cover some of those a bit later.
And then thirdly, and this is perhaps the
most interesting part of cloud computing,
is it's increasingly as a
programming platform.
It's a set of platform services-- and we'll
go through what some of those are a little
bit later-
- with very rich and powerful platform services
that we can use to build our own very interesting
applications often
more quickly, more reliably, more securely
than we might be able to do if we built them
locally.
And we might run those applications on the
cloud itself as I sort of show in the lower
right here.
Or we might build
applications that run in our lab but that
happen to use some of these platform services
to, for example, manage
workflows or store results of computations.
Those hybrid sorts of things are often very
interesting.
Now, so here, just to give you an idea of--
when I say that there's a lot of platform
services, this is a figure that
shows the platform services provided by one
particular cloud vendor, Amazon Web Services.
And I won't go
through them here in any detail, but certainly
you'll get the idea that there's a lot of
them.
You'll see they cover the topics compute and
storage certainly, but also other areas like
content delivery, workflow
management, notification services, monitoring.
In fact, this is only a subset of all the
services that Amazon
provides.
And people are starting to use these sorts
of services to write some very interesting
data science
applications.
And I may have time to say a bit about those
later.
One thing that this emergence of this new
programming platform if you like has spurred
an incredible variety of
software as a service capabilities.
So this is actually quite an old slide, it's
six years old.
Bessemer, venture capital
firm, hasn't created a new version of it recently,
at least not in this format.
But this was a their attempt to capture
as I said the top 300 companies that were
providing various forms of software as a service
or platform as a
service capabilities to enterprises.
Of course, a few of these are relevant to
science, most of them are not.
Hopefully, I believe we're going to see an
emergence of a more scientifically focused
software and platform as a service offerings
in the coming years.
I
mentioned in the abstract for this lecture
and I'll mention here.
Well, myself and my colleague, Dennis Gannon,
recently produced a book called Cloud Computing
for Science
and Engineering that really goes far more
deeply than I can in this hour or so-- into
this question of what cloud
computing is and how it can be used for science
and engineering.
So I'm going to use a variety of components
from that book as I proceed through the rest
of this lecture.
And I should emphasize that this is not just
a bad sales job.
You can buy this book, but the contents are
all entirely
online at cloud4scieng.org.
So you're able to enjoy it without some purchasing
the book.
Although, it does make a
nice present for your family and so forth.
Anyway, so let me just show you what goes
into the online system because it has a couple
of interesting features.
So, of course, we brought the contents of
the book and available in something that looks
quite pleasant.
And you'll
see sort of what the topics we cover, and
these are the topics and then a review very
briefly in this lecture.
How you use the cloud as a platform-- sorry
as a virtual computer.
How you manage data in the cloud.
How you
can compute in the cloud.
And then how you use the cloud as a platform.
How you make the services that are
available for things like data analytics,
streaming, machine learning.
I'll say a bit about something called the
Globus research data management platform,
which is cloud hosted and is often used in
science.
I won't talk today, but the book does talk
a bit about how to build your own cloud.
How to configure a cluster of
your own to run some of these data management
and computing management services.
And I won't also talk
today about security and privacy, but there's
a lot of material in the book on that.
And of course, that's a very
important topic for many purposes.
So that's the content of the book.
The other interesting thing here, and I'd
really like to just convey it to you briefly
is we have a set of Jupiter notebooks.
Hopefully, many of you are familiar with Jupiter,
a web-based interactive
computing environment.
So we have some 23, I think it is, Jupiter
notebooks that allow you to try-- well, observe
or experiment with develop applications using
the various technologies that are described
in this book.
And this is what a Jupiter notebook looks
like for those of you who are not familiar
with it.
And here we are using it
to run the Python.
We use Python really for all of the examples
in the book pretty much.
And Jupiter notebooks
has a series of cells, each of which contain
Python code, and you can run the cells online
using your web browser.
And you create inline graphics or, as we often
do, manipulate and access cloud computing
services to do things
like retrieve data, store data, or run computing
and then so forth.
OK, so let me just spend a few minutes now
talking about some of the capabilities that
you're going to get from cloud computing at
the infrastructure level.
The
cloud is virtual computer.
So what does your desktop computer provide
to you?
It provides computing and storage.
It does other things
because, of course of, the software that it
runs.
But computing and storage are the two fundamental
capabilities.
And similarly, cloud computing providers offer
a very rich set of storage as a service options.
And these implement
as we show here a variety of different storage
models.
There are certainly file system models so
that you can read and write files just as
you would on your desktop
machine.
But there are also other important storage
models offered as well.
So object storage was the first cloud
storage service provided by Amazon some quite
a few years ago now and is one of the most
popular.
It's important relates to the fact that it's
highly scalable, reliable and relatively inexpensive
compared to some of
the others.
But as well as objects storage, which we'll
say more about in a minute.
They provide relational
database citizens, NoSQL database services,
graph database services, warehouse analytics
services and so
forth.
What I'm showing here in terms of each of
these columns is what offerings each of the
three major cloud vendors
provides-- Amazon, Google, and Azure.
And you'll see that they all have often very
similar, sometimes rather
different versions of these capabilities.
So it's not unusual now to see people building
data analytics services that
maintain the data that's being manipulated
in an object store or relational data service.
Compute on the data on the cloud and then
write results back to other cloud services
before [INAUDIBLE] the
computing.
And we'll see examples of that in a second.
A few words about the object storage model.
The basic
idea is similar across all systems.
Your storage universe is divided up into buckets
called-- sometimes, they're
called containers.
They're sometimes called buckets.
And within a bucket, you can place often very
large numbers of objects.
And the the cloud service then provides
the application programming interfaces and
other methods for putting things into containers,
for retrieving them
from containers, or associating attributes
with containers and so forth.
So we'll see an example of that in a minute.
But one other thing we're showing here is
that one thing that the object storage commonly
support is in some form
of versioning, which can be important, of
course, if you are concerned about reproducible
science and being able
to track changes to your data over time.
So that's the object model.
I'll just show briefly how it is realized
in one particular cloud service, Amazon.
And I use
this example really to convey an other notion
which is that most of the services that cloud
providers offer support
both web interfaces for interactive use.
So the top here, I'm creating a new buck called
Cloud for Science.
You'll see what I get [INAUDIBLE] where I
want to create it.
No, I can't place it.
There are different data centers
operated by cloud providers and depending
on where I think most of the accesses will
come.
[INAUDIBLE] may
place it one location or another.
And, of course, being able to use a web interface
is often a very nice way of
manipulating things.
But then typically there are application programming
interfaces in software development kits
that allow me to do anything I can do with
a web interface and often more programmatically.
So down in the bottom, I've got some Python
code that's basically doing the same thing
as I just showed here.
First of all, I delete the bucket I just created
with the web interface.
And then I create it specifying that I want
it
located in the US standard region.
And then I put in put an object into that
nearly created bucket.
So you can do some amazingly sophisticated
things using fairly simple Python code.
So I won't to say more about
storage.
There are some other wonderful storage services.
Let me say a bit about computing in the cloud
now.
So
sort of just summarize some of the key concepts
by showing the table of contents from the
online book.
So computing as a service at the most fundamental
level is offered typically in the form of
either visual machines
or containers.
And I'll say more about is between those in
a minute.
Serverless computing, I'll also say more about
a little bit further on.
But each cloud service offers mechanisms that'll
allow you to create virtual machines, create
one instance of a virtual machine-- 10, 100,
1,000-- configured with whatever software
you want.
And then there are services that let you manage
large numbers of such virtual machines.
For example, you may
run MapReduce computations across them.
You might define a computing graph or workflow
that runs on them.
You can also run message passing interface
computations across them.
The cloud systems don't tend to offer the
ultra high speed communication interfaces
that might be required for
high performance computing, [INAUDIBLE] at
very large scale.
But they seem to do reasonably well up to
at least
a few hundred nodes in many cases, which is
often what one needs for ones or scientific
applications.
Unless
you're dealing with extremely large scale
simulations.
So those are some of the concepts, I think--
serverless is sort of special and we'll come
back to that.
But the rest
of them are the sorts of things that you might
reasonably do on your local computing system.
A little bit about so
virtual machines versus containers.
Perhaps many of you are familiar with the
distinctions here.
A container is, in some sense, a more lightweight
version of a virtual.
A virtual machine is something that lets you
run a particular application in a particular
set of libraries in a particular operating
system on a computer without
having to have that computer dedicated to
that operating system.
So if you're a software is designed to run
on a
particular version of Linux or a particular
version of Windows, you can stand up a virtual
machine with that
software, including the operating system,
deployed and ready to go.
And containers work in a similar fashion except
they organize themselves slightly differently
internally.
And as the
table with the bottom points out, containers
are being increasingly used for many things,
including data science
because they're more lightweight.
They can be deployed very rapidly.
They can be created and destroyed rapidly.
And for various reasons they are quite portable
from one cloud to another thanks to technologies
like Docker and
Singularity which I won't say more about.
So just point out that as with storage, so
with computing, the cloud
providers offer web interfaces that let start
and managed instances.
So here I'm looking at a Amazon compute
virtual machine interface.
And you can see I've got three actual machine
instances-- two are stopped; one is running.
In fact, it's in the
middle of the initializing.
And I could launch additional ones if I wanted.
So just with a click of a button, I can create
a new computing system.
And, of course, if I don't want to click buttons,
in Azure Storage I can also create
instances using, for example, a Python API.
Or so on the bottom here, I'm creating one
instance of a particular type, a micro type,
so [INAUDIBLE] not a very
powerful instance using a specified virtual
machine image in the US west region.
I could also be creating 1,000
instances of very powerful computers using
the same API.
To give you a feeling for what sorts of things
that you
can do with these capabilities.
So this is a pipeline developed by a group
at Chicago working with people at USC and
ISD and in Seattle.
So what
they wanted to do was-- I won't go to the
technical details-- but to run a computational
process that would find
potential [INAUDIBLE] binding sites within
large amounts of DNA's [? secA ?] data from
encode.
And the pipeline involved running various
popular applications-- SNAP Aligner, [INAUDIBLE],
Tool, a couple of
different footprint finding applications.
And running this over large amounts, terabytes
of data-- well, actually it's
more tens of gigabytes of data but producing
along the way terabytes of data from as a
side effect of the
computation.
So this is something that would be pretty
hard to run on one's desktop or even in a
typical lab.
But because we
use Amazon Web Services, we can fire this
up on many multi-core nodes and run the whole
thing in a couple of
hours I think using, in this case, 749 load
hours during computation.
And then the results of the data is retrieved
from the encode system.
The results are eventually deployed onto
Amazon storage.
So it isn't a typical many scientific applications,
we are using a mix of cloud and non-cloud
computing resources to do what we want to
do.
I just mentioned very briefly that for those
in the scientific space
who are interested in working with cloud computing
but don't want to use public cloud resources
[AUDIO OUT]
There are a number of academic cloud providers
that one can work with.
Perhaps, the most accessible is
Jetstream.
It's operated by the National Science Foundation,
or operated for the National Science Foundation
by
the University of Indiana.
So jetstreamcloud.org, you can head there
and request a start up account quite easily.
And then you can do the sorts of things I've
been showing already-- create a virtual machine,
create containers,
store data, and so on and so forth.
My [INAUDIBLE] in Chicago uses this quite
a bit and they find it very, very easy
to do work [INAUDIBLE].
OK, a few words about the cloud as a virtual
computer, a place where you can store data
and compute.
But what I think makes the cloud really exciting
is its capabilities in terms of our platform.
So what do I mean by a
platform here?
It's set of services that cloud providers
operate that you can access via APIs and,
therefore,
integrate into your applications, which may
run either locally or remotely-- either on
the cloud or on your own
computer-- to do things that would be very
difficult for you to do locally.
So I guess the storage services we've already
talked about already have a sort of a platform
characteristic.
If I
want to write an application that runs in
my lab and stores all the data coming off
my estimates into a object store
while indexing them in a database, I can do
that via a simple point on a script that calls
suitable cloud storage
APIs.
But the services that we describe in this
slide and the next one actually allow us to
do a lot more than simply
store a bit of data.
So let me say just a few words about each
of them.
So there's a variety of data analytics services.
Some of these
are simply things that let you run method
use computations or spark.
They're actually spark computations.
So
computations that perform parallel analysis
of a large quantities of data.
There are other services like Google Cloud
Datalab lab and Amazon Athena Analytics that
provide more
sophisticated built in analytic capabilities.
There's a very rich set of services offered
by various providers that deal
with data streaming.
So data coming off a scientific instrument,
you might might set up a streaming service
that
would receive the each image as it is produced
and then does something with it.
Perhaps, processes it, stores the results
in a database, notifies people that it's available.
Those are the sorts of
things that one that implement very easily
using things like Google Dataflow, Kafka,
and Kinesis from Amazon and
other [INAUDIBLE] services.
I may say a bit more about that later if time
permits.
And then there's a growing set of very powerful
machine learning services being provided by
a all of the major
cloud providers.
And I think this is a particularly exciting
set of capabilities for various reasons.
In particular
because good machine learning often requires
access to powerful computing capabilities.
Specialized capabilities
like GPUs, graphical processing units, large
amounts of data, large quantities of computing.
And these are all our easily accessible for
a price needless to say on these commercial
cloud providers.
And they
also provide those computing resources along
with pre-configured software to that implements
of various machine
learning methods.
And partly that's possible because there is
such a rich collection of open source software
for
various forms of machine learning, deep learning
and other similar techniques.
Partly because these cloud vendors see this
as a differentiator.
So they're constantly competing to try and
offer
the best set of this such software on their
platforms.
So down at the bottom, I just described briefly
one of the
services that Amazon offers.
It has a pre-configured virtual machine image
which implements a variety of
different-- AMI, by the way, is Amazon Machine
Image.
So they have a deep learning AMI which includes
a whole range of different platforms.
I have lots of examples and
so forth.
So we can fairly quickly run through and apply
some of these methods.
So one of the notebooks that we
supply, number 21, we use this to see what
happens when we try and apply a pre-trained
model.
A model that's
been trained on a large publicly available
image net-- the data set.
The data set is called image net-- to some
biological images.
So I won't go through all of the code.
It's only 50 lines or so of code that set
this up.
It loads in the image net data.
It loads in the image net model.
And then we apply this to our four images
that we featured in the resulting model.
And so we've got some yeast, the bacteria,
an amoeba, and a seahorse.
And then we're taking the pre-train model.
It's been trained on public data.
It isn't particularly specialized for
biology, but nevertheless, you'll see they
come up with a set of labels for these images
along with their-- like some
measure of their confidence.
And then you see the top ratings for each
of them is actually correct.
So they all do
well.
The yeast and seahorse, their confidence is
less high.
But nevertheless, it does show you that with
essentially no
effort, it's possible to apply some quite
sophisticated machine learning techniques
to data.
I mean, I could be
running this labeling system and data coming
out of a lab and sometimes it might provide
some useful capabilities.
Of course, if we were doing this seriously,
it would take forever.
Versions of this network that have been trained
perhaps with more larger quantities of more
biologically relevant data.
And nevertheless, we can do very well just
out of the gate.
Now, let me mention something else that think
is important about cloud computing.
And this is how one may develop applications
for cloud platforms.
So I talked briefly virtual machine, showed
how
you stand up with virtual machine, which virtual
machine can you contain just the software
that you would normally
run on your workstation.
It might run an application that simply reads
in some data or apply some data analytics
function to it and writes out the results.
And that is basically doing what we do at
home but doing it in the cloud
instead of locally.
We might be doing that for reasons of stability
or access to specialized resources.
But increasingly people are
developing applications on the cloud in a
rather different manner.
And I think it's important to understand that
if
you start thinking about using cloud for your
own purposes.
And what they're doing is building what people
call
cloud native applications.
And this picture down here really shows what's
involved.
So on the left, we have how we might build
an application
on a desktop perhaps or on the cloud.
You have a set of virtual machines or containers,
each of which has some
data in it and some computing logic.
And they do whatever our data analytics or
other computations that we want
to perform.
So these are systems of what we call stateful.
Each of these virtual machines has its own
local file system in which
it's storing data or if it wants to communicate
data to another virtual machine, perhaps it
writes it to a shared file
system or sends it a message or something.
But the reliability of these sorts of applications
is potentially
challenging because if your virtual machine
fails, then you've lost the data that was
stored in it.
So that's not ideal.
A cloud native application will typically
be structured in this sort of format, "all
state."
The data you are analyzing,
the results of an analysis and so forth are
stored in some cloud storage service.
And these are designed to be
highly reliable or replicate data across multiple
geographic regions so they'll maintain multiple
copies of the data.
And they'll keep track of which copies are
up to date and so forth.
And then the computation is performed by a
stateless computation, stateless services,
that might to get created
just for the purpose of performing your analysis.
If they fail-- no problem.
You simply rerun the analysis.
And this
has a number of advantages, it's the resulting
systems are more reliable.
They can also be more easily scaled up
and down as the amount of computation that
needs to be formed that changes over time.
So anyway, this is a
quite an old example that I still think it's
a very good one.
This is the structures used by an application
called ANIMOTO.
I don't know if any of you have heard of it.
It's a
system that takes a set of slides-- oh, no
sorry pictures-- and creates a little music
video with the pictures that you
provide to it, so no scientific interest.
But since it's not atypical of many data analysis
applications, in science
you've got some input images.
You do some processing of them and then some
further processing.
After you've done the analysis, you do, in
this
case, rendering.
And then you distribute the results, perhaps
it could be pushing the data to a public repository
or
making it available to people in some other
way.
And this is implemented as a cloud native
application.
So all states are stored in an object store,
the Amazon S3 object store.
And there's a set of virtual machines
varying numbers of them over time that handle
things like interact upload, data upload,
the analysis, the
rendering, and distribution.
If nothing is happening, maybe no virtual
machines are associated or perhaps just one
of each.
As load increases then more virtual machines
are provided.
You'll see a reference here to a service called
Amazon SQS.
This is the Simple Queuing Service which is
one of a number of similar services operated
by
different cloud providers that basically does
what you would think it-- it operates a queue
into which your request
to do things can be placed in from which--
so your virtual machine can extract our elements.
So cloud native is, as I said, increasingly
the way that people build applications.
So if you simply want to analyze
some data of your own, you're not going to
be particularly concerned about cloud native.
But if you want to create
a service that will analyze lots of data for
lots of people then you might well want to
structure it in the form that I've
just shown you.
And this is increasingly easy to do given
the capabilities that are offered by the various
cloud
providers.
One interesting step beyond cloud native is
what people call a Function-as-a-Service.
So in the example I just
showed you, we have these virtual machines--
you create the virtual machine.
It runs some basic logic-- you know
wait for a task to be available, do some computation,
store the result back into storage.
Sorry, wrong way.
In what's called Function-as-a-Service, the
whole need to create and manage these virtual
machines is automated.
So that all one has to do is simply specify
a function that you want to have executed
when
certain events occur.
And so, for example, here is a simple example.
This is a function that responds to events--
messages appearing on this system I mentioned
briefly earlier, Kinesis.
So the event might be that a new image is
available from an instrument in your lab.
We're using it-- at least, it's for
this purpose that I want.
And each time such an event happens, we've
configured this function so that it will be
executed being past the details of the event
and some context and-- You don't need to read
the details, but what
you'll see it does is it reaches inside the
event, grab some information, and then loads
it into a database, a
dynamodb, db-- database.
So 15 lines or so of code, I've specified
what needs to happen whenever the data is
generated by an instrument in
my lab.
And I don't need to be worrying about managing
virtual machines or scaling up the number
of machines
and circle I just need to specify the function.
OK, getting to sort of one more topic I want
to cover, and then we'll
wrap up.
So one of the things that we as scientists
can do with cloud is to use it to provide
services to other scientists.
And
my group at Chicago does this, we operate
a service called Globus which provides some
capabilities for research
data management.
And specifically, I show here two of them,
the ability to manage the transfer of data
from, for
example, a sequencing center to cloud storage
or to your institutional storage.
And then manage who's allowed to access sharing
of that data.
And this global software is actually a cloud
made
of servers, it runs on Amazon.
So every time you make a request to it, it
is a message gets queued in similar
fashion to what I showed a few minutes ago.
It's dequeued, a transfer is negotiated and
managed and tracked as
it receives.
If you request that certain data be shared
with other people and similar various tables
will be updated to reflect the
fact that some other users of is allowed to
access your data.
The data itself doesn't need to go near the
cloud, it's
just the control logic that runs very reliably
and securely on Amazon because that's what
cloud platforms are good
for.
And like any other cloud service, there's
a web interface which looks a bit like this.
There's also a Python API
so you can say that I want to move data from
one computer to another by using this submit_transfer
request and
then waiting for it to complete it if that
is what I want to do.
OK, so that is a very brief review of cloud
computing and why it matters for data science.
So just to remind you,
the cloud is-- you can view it as a virtual
computer where you can manage data and perform
computing.
You can
also view it as a platform that you can link
into your own applications that you can use
to build new sorts of
applications that perform things like data
analytics, management of streaming data, and
machine learning, data
movement and so forth without having to deploy
a lot of complex software on your own local
computers.
So why, therefore, does the cloud matter for
data science?
Well, these are reasons that occurred to me.
You may
have others.
It certainly provides you with on-demand computing
and storage.
Of course, it comes at a price.
You
will have to pay for these services, but for
many computing applications the costs are
modest relative to the time
that you might spend meeting those costs in
other ways.
You can get access to specialized hardware
certainly, graphical processing units and
so forth.
What I find most
exciting, of course, is this rich collection
of platform services that let you build new
classes of applications.
For
example, using this cloud native programming
model.
And you can do these things in a way that
achieves
sustainability-- high availability.
But you will read occasionally about events
when the cloud services become inaccessible,
but they're only news
because they're so rare.
They're certainly more available than any
computing platform that I have access at any
institution or lab that I might work with.
And similarily, the security-- you've got
very complex and sophisticated
systems in place to manage the security of
these platforms.
Increasingly, people are using them infact
to manage
data and so forth and finding that works well
for them.
So I think that's when the last slide, so
thank you very much
for your attention.
Thank you so much, Ian.
That was a great overview of cloud computing
and why it should matter for data science.
I would like to ask folks who are listening
in, so if you do have any questions for Dr.
Foster to please submit them
via the question submission system.
And I'll do my best to get to them.
One question that we had, you mentioned
it sort of at the end there-- I think it's
probably worth some further thoughts from
you-- is the notion of security and
whether-- just at a time kind of when people
are getting used to the notion of cloud computing,
we're starting to
see some sort of bad examples of potential
security issues.
I know there was a issue with a couple of
things that
go by the terms of Meltdown and Spectre which
sounds terrible.
What sort of implications did these types
of things
and other security issues have for cloud computing
and peoples' and institutions', I guess, comfort
with it.
Well, those are good questions.
My view is in general that a cloud computing
platform is going to be more secure
than any institution's computing platform
simply because there are more people, more
highly trained people, more
sophisticated people managing security in
a place like Amazon.
There are these recent events that you
mentioned, they're certainly of concern.
I think they're a concern for anyone using--
whoops.
I don't know what
happened there-- anyone who is using computers
anywhere, I'm sure the cloud vendors are on
top of them.
There are versions-- I should also mention
there are different levels of security in
the cloud.
Some of the things
that one has to worry about in your local
computers, you also have to worry about there.
You have to make sure
that you're running the latest version of
software.
That's important.
There are different levels of-- for example
Amazon runs the regular cloud and also dove
cloud, which is designed
for highly secure data that, for example,
can't leave the country.
And so you also need to be aware of what the
capabilities are that they might make available
to you.
Of course.
So you're based in part at Argonne National
Laboratory, which I presume is involved in
a lot of atom
smashing and other sorts of particle physics
and other types of things.
And I imagine that you've got a lot of
experience in examples of physics and astronomy
and possibly working with CERN and other major
organizations
looking at either the very small or the very
distant.
Maybe you could say a couple of comments on
that and what's
kind of come out of some of your interactions
with those folks, and also if you've been
doing any stuff that has
biomedical relevance that people might be
interested in hearing about.
Well, so, looking particularly at Argonne,
one area that we spend a fair bit of time
on is working with specialized
experimental facilities, like the Advance
Photon Source which high energy X-ray source.
It runs a number of
beamlines, a number of which are specialized
for biomedical or biological applications,
crystallography,
tomography, other methods.
And then increasingly, they're finding that
they need high performance computing or
least on-demand computing to enable instantaneous
analysis of data as it is collected rather
than as was used to
be the case sending the data home on a USB
drive or I guess floppy disk in the old days.
And so we're finding that
they need these sorts of computing models
that I was talking about here.
And in fact, we're starting to use a mix of
cloud services to manage and dispatch computations
and then high
performance computing facilities at Argonne
to actually do the data reduction, the data
analysis, and so forth.
A
number of these increasingly have a sort of
machine learning component to them, perhaps
for detecting errors or
labeling data.
And so we're finding that our computing facilities
at Argonne are starting to evolve from things
that have been
focused almost exclusively on simulation to
increasingly being used for data analysis,
learning, and so forth.
And
that's one of the reasons why we recently
established the Data Science of Learning Division
at Argonne, which
we're just setting up at the moment and which
will be focused on those sorts of applications.
Oh, it's great.
One thing that someone had asked about is
when you were discussing the ENCODE project,
you
mentioned something about the BDBag and the
[? baggage ?] methodology.
Do you care to elaborate a little bit
more on that?
And is there some easy way to know when you
might want to use that?
Yeah.
So this is something that came out of the
BDBag.
It stands for big data bag and I think-- well,
maybe we
don't need to look at the slide-- but one
of the slides showed us exchanging data between
phases of the
computation using this notation.
It's a set of conventions that originally
came out of the library community, the socalled
Bagit specification.
It's a very lightweight set of rules and functions
for bundling up some data and
associated metadata all in terms of files
in a defined file system structure and using
JSON format to represent
metadata, checksums, and others such information.
We developed this in collaboration with people
with USC.
And we find that whenever we have a computation
that
involves multiple phases where one phase we
might want to run, produce some data, and
then perhaps run the
other phase later or on a different computer,
it works well to underlock the results on
this BDBag format.
And we've got some nice tools that have now
been developed by the community for managing
these BDBags for
checking the integrity of the data, and using
the checksums for retrieving elements of a
BDBag when the contents
are not the actual file but a URL.
We have galaxy tools for accessing and loading
pipeline tools for processing
data that are contained in these BDBags and
so on and so forth.
So, Ian, we're almost at the end of our time
here.
But I want to give you a minute or two here
just to kind of
forecast where you see grid and cloud computing
in the next five years.
Will we be like dispensing with doing local
computing all together and just shipping it
out to the ether?
Or do you see any alterations?
How's it going to
change our lives in the next five years?
Yeah, I think that's a good question.
So of course we'll still have academic computing
centers.
But they will
perhaps be more focused on the very high end
simulations and other computations that can't
be performed on
cloud computing platforms.
I think particularly for smaller institutions,
they need to be looking very hard at where
does it make sense to compute locally versus
remotely, and looking at doing sort of a full
cost analysis, and also
trying to understand the trade-offs involved
in having to maintain and then compete for
time on a overloaded local
system versus being able to reach out to a
cloud service.
But then the other area where we hopefully
will see great progress is in the services
that are operated on cloud
platforms for scientists.
We're seeing a growing number of these.
But I think we can go much further.
Perhaps the
cloud, in one form or another, will hopefully
be the place where we can process the data
about millions of patients
that's starting to become available from various
programs in the US and abroad.
It seems impractical to imagine
every institution setting up the machinery
required to collect, to create a copy of a
million genomes and analyze
them, but a central cloud hosted facility
could quite reasonably be used for that purpose.
Well, we'll look forward to that time.
But we've reached the end of our time though
today.
And I'd like to thank Dr.
Ian Foster from the University of Chicago
and Argonne National Laboratory once again
for telling us why the cloud
matters for data science.
And I want to thank everybody who joined us
today for tuning in into The Big Data to
Knowledge Guide to the Fundamentals of Data
Science.
Once again, thank you, everyone.
Thank you, Dr. Foster.
And everybody have a wonderful extra long
weekend.
And we'll see you again for the next BD2K
Guide to the Fundamentals of Data Science
next week.
Thanks,
everybody.
Take care.